hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's
new Supergirl footage and we saw a bunch
of the new comic book characters that
one that wasn't in the trailer that we
have seen before though is Red Tornado
they released a picture of him so I'm
just gonna do a brief explainer for each
of these characters starting with the
biggest one Maxwell Lord I would be
amazed if you guys had not seen Peter
Facinelli before I won't judge you
depending on where you saw him no
judging here but let's just say he does
a really good job of playing villains
with poise or you know characters that
are relatively complicated I think just
because of his physicality I think it'd
be harder for him to play one of the
comic book characters that there's a lot
of punching and kicking the ones that
Supergirl is gonna be fighting with WWE
style you could think of Maxwell Lord is
like a really quiet subtle psychopath a
lot of his big comic book storylines
pain him that way but really he's just
another character like Malcolm Merlyn on
arrow he has a grand design that just
clashes with the heroes grand design we
don't know exactly how the show's gonna
introduce him but he looks more like a
wealthy businessman than a government
official
most of my exposure to Maxwell Lord
started after identity crisis during his
checkmate years but if you go further
back in the comics he was actually a
longtime friend of the Justice League he
was very influential in their creation
he helped bring a lot of them together
it was during the countdown to Infinite
Crisis when he really went dark when
they took the character super dark
they retcon some of his backstory and
said that during his years with the
Justice League when he was arguably
doing good things he was secretly
collecting information on all the
world's superheroes I know we've been
talking about Blue Beetle and Booster
Gold a little bit lately he actually
ends up killing the Ted Kord Blue Beetle
at the end of that story that was what
really set the stage for the next Blue
Beetle to come along the Jaime Reyes
character based on some of this footage
it seems like he's gonna be interacting
with both the super characters and with
Kat grants character so he'll straddle
both of the different worlds of the show
I gave the storyline where Supergirl is
trying to hunt down aliens then you have
her life as Kara like her life during
the daytime and obviously there's gonna
be times when those two things will
overlap we're like she'll have to do
Supergirl things in the middle of a
workday and then there'll be straight-up
times when she's only interacting with
characters as Supergirl like when she's
out on patrol at night most of you
probably know that he's one of the most
powerful telepaths on the earth it just
as a way to keep him from getting too
overpowered the the side effects of
using his push ability like the ability
to push his will on other people causes
him to
nosebleeds weakens him if you guys never
read brightest day it's a really good
Geoff Johns Green Lantern comic book it
was one of the last Green Lantern
storylines he wrote so in that Maxwell
Lord gets resurrected and then tries to
erase all memory of him from everyone's
minds on the planet he calls it his
biggest push ever he had to enhance his
abilities with tech but it causes his
brain to hemorrhage big time later in
that storyline he actually becomes one
of the white Lantern's I think that was
just Geoff Johns way of having fun with
a villain character they're just like a
couple of villains that are chosen as
guardians of all life in the universe
but if you want to read more about that
just check out that storyline I don't
think the TV show is gonna be doing any
specific comic book storyline but if I
do spot anything I'll mention it
whatever I make videos a really good
example of the TV shows doing comic book
storylines is the flash season one they
kind of did a version of flash rebirth
where Barry Allen comes back into the DC
Universe they changed a lot of things
about the characters backstories but the
framework of the story was there
Barry trying to go back in time and save
his mother from dying so don't be
surprised if Supergirl does a version of
a comic book storyline during season one
next big villain hellgrammite now he's
mostly a Superman villain that was hired
by Lex Corp originally in the comics but
he also showed up in Suicide Squad one
year later and after prometheus
destroyed Star City during cry for
justice which was kind of a Justice
League story but also a Green Arrow's
story I know everybody wonders as
Supergirl is gonna cross over with arrow
in the flash the person at CBS that said
that they originally weren't planning on
sharing Supergirl with other networks is
actually out she actually left her job
so maybe we can change that I'm not
expecting any crossover in season one
though helper might is a man-made super
villain he actually subjected himself to
this mutagenic process which gave him
these grasshopper insect-like features
most of his superpowers are insect based
like he could we've really strong
cocoons around everyone he has a super
strong exoskeleton he can jump really
high he's super strong you can see that
some of these powers are things that
Supergirl can also do like she's super
strong she can jump super far like the
villains they introduced on Supergirl
have to be of a similar power level so
if you're wondering which comic book
characters they're gonna bring onto the
show in the future just think about
characters that can match her abilities
that's how I think they were able to get
Red Tornado because I was energy kind of
hoping that that character would going
to flash because T omorrow the character
that creates him I mean he's he's a
supervillain he used to work at STAR
Labs
just like Arthur liked it you know if
you remember that arrow season to shout
out
Arthur light the crazy guy that got
fired all of his texts fill in the
basement what I'll say about his look is
that this is probably not what he's
gonna look like when we actually see him
in an episode I was kind of hoping that
he'd be a deeper shade of bread but I
think what they're doing is is that
they're just gonna fix that in post
production it's like the way grant
gustin's flash costume looks when it's
not on screen like when you see behind
the scenes pictures the color looks a
little bit duller and then when you see
it in the final completed episode it
looks color corrected it's nice and
shiny so I think it's gonna be the same
deal with Red Tornado because they
actually his shade of red is pretty
close to the Flash's costume shade of
red next big villain reactron also
another villain that's been part of the
Suicide Squad at various points in the
comics the two biggest storylines that
he's been featured in lately I mean
relatively lately were the New Krypton
storyline which is actually a while ago
that was a good Brainiac storyline and
then blackest night I really recommend
just checking out the new Krypton
storyline it's a great Superman story
anyway now in the comics his power just
allows him to generate blasts of
radiation but it looks like he's firing
energy he also has a heart made of gold
kryptonite now I don't know if they're
gonna do that on the TV show he might
get a villain upgrade later in this
series but I really don't know what role
kryptonite is gonna play in the TV show
it does exist though if you remember in
the first Man of Steel movie like in the
in the DC movies kryptonite does not
exist on earth it will however after
Batman V Superman kryptonite will become
a thing here's my big question for you
guys which characters do you want to see
go on the TV show like I know a lot of
people want to see Lex Luthor and some
of the other big Superman characters but
I think some of them will only be
allowed to show up in the movies
I think Maxwell Lord is gonna be the
stand-in for people like Lex Luthor like
the very corporate very well-connected
villains just think about characters
that are of a similar power level to
Supergirl so like Martian Manhunter
haven't heard anything about him showing
up in the movies that would totally
leave him free for the TV show and he
was another character that was on
Smallville
like Smallville did their version of
Maxwell Lord you know a couple
characters that we're gonna see the
funny thing is is that the actor that
played Maxwell Lord on Smallville was
also on Ally McBeal with Calista
Flockhart so it's all connected and it
also proves that I watched too much
television as you may have seen they've
actually changed
premiere date so they moved it up it's
gonna be October 26 that's on a Monday
night at 8:30 p.m. like right after a
Big Bang Theory then the week after that
it's gonna move to 8:00 p.m. so Monday's
we're gonna have Gotham and Supergirl
then Tuesday we'll have the flash and
agents of shield and then Wednesday will
have arrow there's a bunch of the TV
shows that I haven't mentioned yet but
those are just the ones that are coming
back first so be sure to subscribe to
get everything and there is some new
flash footage that I'm gonna talk about
next
so that's gonna be my next video today
I'll try to get that out as fast as
possible it's not a new trailer it's
more of like a sneak peek but they do
talk about some things that we haven't
heard about before so while you guys
wait for that flash video to post you
can click here for my Gotham season 2
episode 1 video it just aired make sure
you watch it if you haven't seen it yet
and you can click here for all my other
arrow flash trailers thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight